welcome back to Jenna and Julian's
podcast welcome thank you for watching
we've done this like 10 times cuz we
keep [__] it up so many things
happening this is our special guest
Brett
BR get legs get Brett thanks for having
me yeah thanks for being here Brett this
is really special he's our first guest
on the podcast yep uh Brett is our best
friend he hangs out with us like every
weekend I met Brett through work he
works at uh I should say I work at the
station that he works at amp radio but
yeah Brett's here to hang out with us
I'm here he's here we're going to talk
about stuff all the stuff all the stuff
all of it all of it and we're going to
drink cider while we do it yeah I got to
get on it you're like a little cider
ahead of me I'm side ahead of you homie
this this podcast brought to you by
[__] no one no rules that's right I
should also say that not only am I the
first guest on your podcast this is the
first podcast I've ever done in my life
yeah get legs this is the first podcast
I've done too lots of first
tonight yep um I think a good little
intro to be explain how I met Brett um
which is uh about I think a little over
two years ago I think when I started at
amp um he he was working the weekends
and I was working the weekends and we
just kind of were in the office at the
same time so um we got to know each
other that way um and yeah I mean as as
we started started getting to know each
other uh we would spend more time just
kind of hanging out at work you know cuz
on the weekends you know like there's
there's not so much it's not a lot to do
it's not a lot to do there a lot of
downtime what you guys do well at the
time he was running the board and I was
answering phones for what I was doing
like contests amp radio amp radio yeah
amp radio amp radio
ampam Bam Bam Bam and Brett was uh he
was running the board which is basically
pressing all the buttons making the St
run um everything that a DJ does without
talking uh but then yeah we started hang
out and I knew Brett before I knew Jenna
so little fun fact there OG OG friend
right
there and now we all love each other
yeah we do yeah we do one one big happy
family [__] love Brett so much
Brett's a man oh my God okay yeah and
and you guys are friends and you guys
have gotten considerably closer and like
the last year yeah yeah yeah yeah
especially since the three of us started
hanging out yeah Jen is like teed glue
te glue te glue te glue to life Brett
come over and uh I'm pretty sure I saved
your phone number with Emojis like dog
emojis yes dog emojis next to Brett's
name not even in Jenna's phone under a
name too cool for name not a name it's
just dog emojis that's the secret to
getting Jenna that's that's the secret
to getting Jenna to text you back just
have her put you in her phone as not a
name just Emoji cuz then she just gets
excited and it's like all right I'll
text this Emoji back mhm um we had a
couple suggestions to talk about oh hash
get Brett let's get that going um I like
that we had a couple suggestions we were
um dancing around with the ideas of best
stories uh about like your worst date
your worst hangover or also uh
significant experiences with the cops
which I have a good story but I mean
what do you guys think what what do you
what do you feel like we should hit I
don't know Brett have you ever had a
really bad date I want to I'm like dying
to know have you ever had a really bad
date yeah
Brett oh God like it's La I I have not
had any bad dates in la oh I have
notthern cnia yeah where were the bad
dates I you know I haven't really had
bad dates to be honest with you [__]
yeah why why did you not have bad I wish
I had a really great I need to go have a
bad date so can the pocket Story Buzz
Buzz is on the table oh he's cool he
that's what Kermit does oh he's grabbing
that
licorice I feel the same way a little
bit I mean I've had like bad girlfriends
and bad relationships I've never had bad
dates like a date is you know what I
mean it's just kind of me what about you
i' I feel like I've only really been on
like a couple actual dates where you
like get to know the person and that
sort of like formal sense it's always s
of been like you know the person you
hang out and it's never really like
dating I think but I think it's like
sort of I don't know it's like our
generation like we don't really date
until you get to a certain age and then
you're like I guess we should like right
go out cuz when you start dating you're
like a poor like 20-year-old it's like
let's go go to McDonald's you want to
you want to come over to my room you
want to take the bus to McDonald's
together we can sit next to each other
watch some Netflix but I I definitely
wait you have Netflix right we can watch
it I don't have it it's my friend's
account but yeah if he's watching right
now we can't watch it so come over later
no I had I had one bad day I feel like I
told you about this I was like I know my
mom's on the E stream right now but
whatever um I was in college and we had
this one fake ID that we had pass around
in between all of us cuz that's how you
would get in but we would always go see
my friend Ashley who sang in a band like
a cover band yeah and uh so it was
always at this one place called Hennessy
and we would get in there when we're
like 19 years old or whatever and uh you
know just be like woo Ashley yeah we and
so the bartender who was like my juce
he's like kind of balding like clearly a
lot older than I was but he would sort
of like always be really nice to me and
whatever and so one night he asked me
for my phone number and I was like yeah
sure here's my phone number and then he
texted me and was like let's grab a
drink sometime and I was like uh the
thing about that is I'm
19 like I get in this bar with a fake ID
do you still want to get a drink he's
like let's grab some dinner like all
right that sounds fine cuz I was single
at the time whatever and then I figured
out that he was 29 and I was 19 and a
10year age difference at that age was
like just a little bit too much for me
to handle because all we could talk
about that we had in common was like
movies and then like we just like had
nothing like totally different pages of
life and also um at one point someone
that he knew was in the we went to
[__] Chili's by the way like
super # romance whatever I would have
been stoked off like going to Chili's I
know I was really excited to get a meal
honestly um but this person 29-year-old
right he can buy you meals seriously um
but this this like woman and her husband
like walked up to the table and was like
Hey so and so like this guy and uh I'm
like oh these are your friends that's
nice and then I looked down and you you
know she's just like super [__]
pregnant and they're like oh who's this
you know clearly like much younger than
you girl what are you guys doing I'm
like hey I'm Jenna I don't I just showed
up I don't know man what like you're
pregnant okay I came for the meal ah it
was just super [__] awkward man you
know what I mean like you're you're on a
date you realize that this person's way
older than you they thought that you
were a different age and then you this
pregnant woman just got to come make it
real awkward [__] weird for everybody
like go away go have your baby thanks it
was [__] weird that is weird that was
a bad date anytime there's like a random
pregnant lady just it's weird there's no
need for that like no need well I have
nothing against pregnant people but I
felt like she was judging me the
pregnant woman was judging you her baby
was judging
me her baby was looking at me with its
little judgmental eyes well you know
sometimes like people are they look so
Pregnant like that it looks like it
physically hurts that's what you look
like look like they're in pain it just
looks like it hurts that's what she
looked like and then I felt like she was
angry at me for existing so I felt weird
it's not nice though why why why so
hostile why is your baby hostile your
baby's judging me anyway she's all
pregnant and unhappy and Jenna's young
and not pregnant exactly Jenna's young
and confused about take bitterness
elsewhere lady get out of chilies get
out of chilies not before you're getting
your Blondie with all mode vanilla ice
cream yes we didn't even get dessert
what wait what I was sad what the I
wanted some dessert I wanted a blondie y
mode yeah shit's banging mhm that's the
only reason you go to
Chili's to get the ice cream why else
would you go to [__]
chili yeah and that was in uh Boston
romance yes super romantic not bad but
I'd say that's one of the only like
actual formal dates I've ever been on
you know yeah I know bad date I mean at
least you don't like show up to a dance
in your PE clothes or something like
that that's just a bad date that's not a
real date though you're young um yeah
that was just poor planning poor that
was no planning you told that story of
my I think the first one yeah yeah about
how I showed up uh and my date was
dressed like it was her prom night and I
was wearing PE clothes but you know what
she didn't care she was so happy that
you just went with her I think she was
and her mom I think her mom cared the
most cuz she's like the one with the
camera how dare you not wear a tux you
12-year-old are those your PE
clothes yes do your shorts say your last
name on them what yeah with
Sharpie yeah they're real
personalized so that they don't get
stolen they they've never been washed
they just get sprayed with axe every
single time you're done using them
yep oh Middle School God how [__]
awkward was that
yeah Middle School was not fun I would
never go back there no thank you Middle
School was the worst the worst yeah it's
just like you're trapped in your own
hell that is like your existence but you
don't realize how miserable it is until
you get out of it and you're like oh my
God life doesn't suck oh no well I was
[__] I was all mentally aware of how
miserable it was well yeah I was like is
this what life is like God what the [__]
what happened to like being a happy
little kid then all of a sudden you're
like why does everyone suck
it's terrible yeah I mean for me I was
just like it was whatever like I didn't
like it but when I got to high school I
was like life can get so much better
like that was bad I didn't realize how
bad it was when I saw the other side I
remember being in middle school and
thinking that high school was going to
be this like like you're so much older
yeah like even seeing the the high
school campus was this like what is even
going on over there you just can't
possibly relate you're like those kids
are like adults right and then you get
there and you're like oh this
is I sort of thought it was going to be
like a magical movie too you know right
you just like go around with your
friends is like the best years of your
life hanging out the quad let them in
jackets it's like all I do is homework
and like sports this is nothing yeah
there's nothing cool happening here at
all no I I feel duped super
duped yeah and it's like you play a
sport it's a completely different
experience when you don't yeah it is
it's like two different schools almost
exactly yeah but it's not true I mean
you can do a lot of other things that
would take up just as much time as like
a sport wood like a club or something I
created a club in high school what was
it the pingpong club what I created the
pingpong club in my high school the
dance club really yeah well [__] you and
we lost the light see I'm telling you
that light is so Shifty just thing I
created the dance club and it just never
took off dance club did you just bring
your big old boom box and just get crazy
weird yeah what did you do in ping pong
Club well we played pingpong but most of
the time I I spent most of my time
designing the pingpong club shirt which
was just two little rackets and then a
words that says Sam O pingpong club I
was so proud of that though went no we
like are $10 guys oh dude I was so proud
and then we had one table you to set it
up yeah and one of these science classes
and you just move into the center and
then slowly just people just stop
showing up but for like years I that on
my resume cuz I was like yeah I started
a club and we played pingpong and I was
the president I'm an innovator my
innovator that is awesome yeah yeah good
work that was fun thank you speaking of
innovation I ate some scrambled eggs out
of a Chinese food container this morning
cuz I had nothing to eat it on yeah you
unfolded it uh apparently that's the
thing that is a thing you can unfold it
into a plate yes okay did you know that
I did know that so but I feel like I
feel like that's one of those things on
the internet that like explodes like
every few months like people re realize
that and it's like trending again yeah
no that that that's the thing I heard
about that yeah what okay so did you do
that or did you just eat it out of no no
no I I I ate it out of there I was happy
with that but um so you didn't make it
up late no I ate it out of the thing
like rice but then someone tweeted at me
and they were like you know that you can
unfold it and I was like I guess the
point is
why bother unfolding it when you can
just shovel it out of I me unless it's
unless you need more space like if you
have too much food to fit in the
container I mean which wasn't the case
cuz it was only like a couple scrambled
eggs I could fit it but you never know
like if I'm trying to eat a meal and all
I have is this little container cuz I
feel like that's a possibility in in my
future that could happen again I did see
your Tweet about this by the way and I
loved the hashtag clean up on Isle mind
that's what I which was amazing see it
wait what did it say I I I wrote the
picture of me eating the eggs and
someone was like you know that you can
unfold it into a plate and I was like
clean up on my mind hashtag hasht it's a
funny hashtag thank you I'm glad you
noticed that's good hashtagging right
there that is a really good hash yeah I
needed to clean up on Isle
mind anyone clean up on a mind I mean I
liked it anyway um Brett you should
follow Brett on Twitter he tweets some
really funu had some really good tweets
he's got good tweets sometimes they're a
little angry I'm trying to not be so
cynical about everything all of mine
were angry today ain't no shame in my
game they're all [__] angry I didn't
see today what were they about um I
don't know I can read that a second um
no but here's the thing I feel like
there's a lot of people who get on
Twitter and just complain and you're
like okay all you do is complain I think
Brett knows who I have in mind right
here but um Brett doesn't do that he he
may sound like cynical sometimes or
negative but it's funny because out
funny at least that's they are they are
the one about when you go grocery
shopping yeah yeah yeah yeah the gum
that was a good one I was proud of that
one what was it yeah tell us uh I don't
remember the exact ad lib I think it was
yeah I just said that the the person the
the the person checking you out at the
grocery store who hands you the pack of
gum should be making 100 Grand a year
and basically they're just the most
awesome human being on the face of they
know what's going on they [__] they get
the way the World Turns they just they
get it yeah they they get it and 100K a
year is a very reasonable salary for
that person starting they awful it's
just customer service you know finest
finest it is the epitome they they could
serve the president in my opinion with
that kind of attitude and work ethic I
mean who's going to want who's going to
want to get home or get to their car and
fish their [__] arm through wet like
bags
of fruit and no you need your gum right
here I'm not going to eat it later I got
I saw it right now I'm eat it right now
that's why you bought it in the aisle
where you're checking out your groceries
and you didn't buy it in the gum aisle
with like packs and packs and pack I it
now you're lucky I didn't steal that
pack of gum I could have just grabbed it
[__] like put it right in my pocket
that's terrible I'm just kidding don't
steal gum don't steal gum my aside from
my tweets about PE last night oh those
were good tweets um I tweeted today the
frequency of hose changing lanes is an
epidemic how many times does The Hip Hop
Community need to tell you to stay in
your lane
ho and then I also tweeted These Hoes
are neither loyal nor do they know how
to stay in their Lane I'm getting tired
of telling them to say my [__] name
also and
uh one
more like I see how you can go through
days where everything seems kind of
negative but you're not no you just you
need to get it out there it's in your
mind I tweeted things I just saw girl
eating corner on the cob while driving
would you mind kindly getting the [__]
out of my face with that
[__] I was like baffled I was driving to
Tyler's house and she's just over there
like with a full not a half one not like
a full corn on the cob
going I'm like what are you doing which
by the way corn on the cob is one of the
messiest things that you food like you
don't do that when you're driving no
you're spilling butter everywhere like
it's like corn it's in your teeth right
you can't drive like that you're
probably a horrible driver to start eat
some oysters next time while you're
driving
oysters I don't even eat fish and that
looks complicated to eat oysters yeah I
crab yeah no that's that's get a giant
king crab your little cober just eat
lobster behind the wheel like crack the
Lobster Dip it in the butter put your
little bib
on the got to have the bib and then you
got to twe about it # bib on the 405 get
at me I got that Lobster in the carpo
lane but you know what I was also
thinking I was writing a check the other
day while I was driving and like you
can't I don't even [__] I don't know
sorry wait just repeat that sentence was
riding a check the other day I wasn't
driving I was stopped and so it was just
on my center console I just needed to
like sign it you know what I mean so I
was like how is it that I can sit here
and have a [__] pen in my hand and a
check but I can't text on my phone or
like do anything on my phone that's
illegal but like I get texting and
driving is incredibly dangerous but
doing many things in driving is
incredibly dangerous corn on the cob why
draw the line at texting right yeah a
just put it back in no you're good no
other that side yeah well Jenna's having
her own little issues anyway the way I
feel about texting and driving is it
should just become part of the DMV test
and you should take a test while and if
you can pass the texting and driving
test you're allowed to do it you get a
sticker for your car yeah maybe after
like that's amazing but after like a
bumper sticker I know my limits I know
that I can text when I'm at a stoplight
right I know that I can send a text when
I'm driving I won't it's already if it's
already in I won't type a text when I'm
driving right I feel like it should be
like up to a certain speed limit like
you can text and drive or like within
your own judgment which I think a lot of
people have good judgment about it a lot
of people have terrible judgment but if
you pass the DMV test you're like not an
idiot you have good judgment and you're
driving you know below 20 M an hour then
maybe that would be like you're not
going to get a big giant [__] fine
because you were just texting someone at
a stop sign or there's no one else at
you're at an intersection with no one
you're technically not even driving
really stopped yeah no I feel really
frustrated when uh like M even just a
map like I want to look at a [__] map
yeah and you pull up at like a light and
you're like okay I know this light it's
not a short light and it just turned red
I want to look at my phone cuz I got to
check my text I got to see the if I'm
going the right way or whatever and you
that feeling of like oh I really hope a
cop doesn't see me it's just so dumb
like I'm not doing anything in danger
anymore yeah like you can't even do this
or you're like in fear of a cop giving
you a [__] $300 ticket in traffic
school like screw that doesn't make
sense it's just not logical no it's not
it's like they threw this blanket over
this texting Problem by saying no
texting and driving like don't look at
your phone [__] eating like think
about put your make putting on makeup
reading a newspaper have you ever seen
someone driving and reading a newspaper
I'm sorry or a map like an 8-year-old
guy with a map open m which by the way I
think in La like with the traffic we see
a lot of crazy people doing insane
things behind the wheel plus we've
noticed that if you're in a really
really really high volume traffic area
like you're Bumper to Bumper you're not
going anywhere you can't get on the
internet because everyone around you is
on the internet we we used to Jenna and
I used to car to the gym in back and we
would hit Olympic like right there and
we couldn't get on the on the on the
internet at all like it was like stopped
her block like whoever like one of us
would be driving the other one would be
like all right I'll look up some jokes
or something on the Internet you just
can't get any service everyone's on
their phone it's like you're being at
it's like you're at a [__] concert no
one can get on the Internet or a
baseball game or a basketball game like
that's it feels just like that and
you're like oh everyone is breaking the
law right
now literally everyone around me it's so
ridiculous and then you the person who
gets pulled over and given the god I
really hope that never happens to me
pulled over ien I really do enough I've
gotten pulled over I've gotten pulled
over I've never gotten pulled over for
this particular because I'm really good
at it I passed the [__] test and you
drive like a normal person while you do
it which is should mean you're allowed
to do it yeah you're not even like
[__] holler at me ho you're like
being [__] I don't know you're using
your brain I can just understand I feel
like there's gray area you know what I
mean Brett got Jesus corn
legs we're just reading things from the
Ustream oh that's good that's a good one
Brett tell us about an experience when
you got pulled over oh yeah okay
so I will admittedly say that there was
a point in my life where I thought about
being a police officer I thought that
that was a good idea and then I moved to
Southern California and I was driving to
I don't even know where I was going but
I was in Riverside County which is in
it's just it's far yeah and I didn't
really know where I was I didn't know
what I was doing I was new to Southern
California and I got pulled over and I'm
like what's going on cuz I genuinely
didn't know what I had done and the cop
walks up to my car and ask me to step
out of the vehicle and I'm like freaking
out you won't won't tell me what
happened won't tell me anything I'm like
panicking cuz I'm literally on the side
of the 10 freeway like cars are whizzing
by I don't know why I'm pulled over
danger it's very dangerous so then he
starts saying all this crazy stuff he's
asking me if I have any drugs on me what
which I'm like no I don't have any no
yeah dude I got like 70 pounds of meth
just look in the center console all in
there you want hit that basically was
what it came down to like I think this
guy thought that I was like trafficking
drugs or something what the [__] but um
long story short he was like threatening
me the whole time and like touching his
gun and like ask he asked me if I had a
dead body in my trunk no he did not he
just straight up asked you like straight
up asked me he's like he's like do you
have a dead body in your trunk okay I
would burst out laughing if that
happened I'm sorry I was so like mind
blown I was like what going on right now
no I was just trying to figure out how
to get out of there cuz at this point we
had been there for like 20 minutes and
he was asking to search my car and I was
like I at that point I was like pissed
so I was like no you can't search my car
I didn't do anything wrong you didn't
right he has no like reasonable yeah he
told that I finally got him to tell me
why he pulled me over which was because
he said because I was driving slower
than the flow of traffic go away right
now anyway I would be furious I'm
resisting him from searching my car and
then finally he's like well I have a
drug dog in my car so I'll if he gets a
hit on anything we'll be out here for
the next 2 hours tearing your whole car
apart so I'm like okay you can search my
car I have nothing in my car like go
ahead so he looks in my trunk and he's
like all right have a great day what a
[__] creep that was it and but but I
will say ever since then I'm like cuz
they just they dude that's unacceptable
that's like no way to I mean even if
you're in the wrong you don't treat I
know that that's how they catch a lot of
idiots you know what I mean but like to
treat citizens like normal law-abiding
citizens
driving they're criminals because you're
driving slower than the speed of traffic
or the flow of traffic like [__] blow
me are you kidding me you have nothing
else better to do like bro I'm in a 96
Honda Civic that's fast go that
fast sorry my brother I know it looks
really beat up and shitty and like
there's probably drugs in the trunk no
me and my brother used to share a car in
high school and it was the same way if
there was you know a lot of things was
like 55 miles hour speed limit but like
there was one area of town where it was
like 65 and the it was a big gray Isuzu
Rodeo and once you hit like 60 it was
like like the whole car is like shaking
everywhere and you're like just go
around all I got is 60 I'm flooring it
like just go this is as good as a all I
got is 60 it's like the older cars like
if somebody pulled me over for that I'd
be like sir my foot was like on the
ground the way that's as fast as it goes
that's [__] it [__] but I
haven't been pulled over since then that
was like two years ago knock out what
cuz I'm I'm very pinoid now no you're a
good driver no that's that's [__]
that's like 100% [__] yeah it's [__]
it's [__] and speaking of cars that
max out like that my Jeep uh the Jeep I
drove in high school I had a Jeep in
high school yeah Grand Cherokee yes I
did that was my very first car a yeah
Grand
Cherokee the mic um every time you pull
up to a light or a stop sign if you
didn't um keep gas going into it it
would turn off so that was my car yeah
it was pretty cool yeah the one that my
brother and I shared it finally died
because uh the whole axle fell apart oh
yeah when my brother was driving it
split in half nice super good time do
you have any good good cop stories an
axle jul has one I have one it makes me
sound like a real deviant though but I'm
not and I wasn't can you put is he kit
you can get in your own bed dude okay uh
all right so I was on Siders we need
some I'm going to get I'm get all right
we allowed to get leave do whatever the
[__] you want no [__] rules no rules
um so I was I think a junior in high
school maybe a sophomore but I was
driving this Jeep on a weekend night I
was driving it with um friend Andrew my
friend Brandon my friend Logan and
someone named Wy who you know he was
cool he was like my friend sort of but I
was closer to the other three and um
somehow wely ends up in the front seat I
just said all their names whatever um he
ends up in the front seat and he had
eggs so he had h a couple of eggs in his
backpack and I don't know what he was
planning on doing with them but we
weren't going for like a ride we were
going somewhere we I think we were going
to a friend's house from my house uh so
we're uh north of Montana which is like
a nice area they have ADT patrol cars at
night just for that area because it's uh
you know all those houses are are I
think just by default protected by those
ad ADT guys at night yeah thanks um
you're the man uh anyway so I am uh I'm
driving and we see an ADT car but he's
up ahead and he's pulled over yeah
they're not cops by way they're not cops
but they are armed they're ad Patrol
they're secure they're highed security
but they have arms so wait can I
interject really quickly about ad Patrol
have you heard about our like creepy ADT
dude at work is he the guy they put
pictures up of or is that a different
guy so supposedly we have this we have
ADD Patrol at work that drives through
the parking lot like every couple hours
or whatever yeah oh okay just to like
make sure everything's cool the the
neighborhood that the station's in is
kind of like kind of sketchy anyway so
supposedly this guy rolls through every
couple hours but he started like
appearing inside the building and like
asking people weird things about people
that worked there I saw email about this
yeah it's like what the [__] the the ADT
dude is like creeping people out so not
only they not cops they're also not
professional they're very creepy well
that little story makes it feel a little
less bad about my story um anyways
you're driving and you saw you saw One
of These Fine people saw One of These
Fine gentlemen uh and a kid in my car
had eggs as I had mentioned before and
um who knows what he was going to do
with them throw them at a car or
whatever but we see an ADT car um and
his lights on like his little you know
console light is on he's pulled over
doing whatever the [__] he's doing and
I'm like all right I'm going to turn
down this street I don't know I just
want to turn down this street and I'm
pulling up to make this left turn I make
I make the left turn and as I'm turning
left I approach this car I'm going to go
past him but I'm driving next to him
because he's parked you know he's
parallel parked there's a car in front
of him and a car behind him and I'm just
like I don't want to look I just kind of
wanted to go down the street and then I
hear and I look to my right and there's
yok running down his window and I'm like
Wy you just [__] threw an egg get
this guy like I didn't even say that cuz
there was no time right like I saw that
happen and I hit the gas like I didn't
even think um I couldn't believe he
[__] did that cuz any of my friends
in the back seat would never have done
that right but Wy
did it's cuz he's Wy I'm assuming wiing
out good joke I'm out that's my time um
so I Flor it down this street and this
is residential probably like 11 or 12 at
night which is oh let there be light
welcome back um residential 11: or 12 at
night like way past my curfew I'm just
in high school um but I fly down the
street in my Jeep like a floor and I
think it hit like probably 50 pretty
fast for a residential street and in my
rearview mirror like this I'm in full
like flight mode right now I see my
rearview mirror he pulled out of that
spot like so fast and he's like gaining
on me so I blow through a stop sign and
make a right turn like I don't even stop
I just whip it to the right and there
wasn't any cars around so it wasn't that
d dous but it was still dangerous and as
soon as I turn right I'm like okay I I
estimate probably like 25 maybe 30 yards
he has behind me to gain so I whip
through the the stop sign and as soon as
I turn right I see an alley and I hit
the left so I go right and then left I
pull into this alley it's like really
bumpy turn off my car without even
thinking turn off pull out the key
lights are off and I look in my rview
mirror and he flies by and he didn't
even know what we did some super fast
some Furious [__] yeah I was going to
say like I was like I told that story I
was so proud of but I was like I can't
even believe that happened being a [__]
bag kid such a [__] bag kid so then I
like get back in the car I like Drive
slowly to my mom's house I'm like guys
get inside and my sister's like can I
take the car and I was like yeah take it
I don't want to be in that car yeah
they're not looking for it or
anything yeah that was and I've been
pulled over a couple times but um yeah
no that's definitely uh one of the
craziest interactions I've had with
police my sister once got a ticket for
sitting down what sitting down sitting
down what does that mean well there's a
sitting on on the ground there's a the
Third Street prominade in Santa Monica
and when you're in high school actually
sorry Middle School it's the place to be
on like a Friday night oh yeah so she
was there with her friends everyone's at
the pr when you're in Middle School like
Friday nights you just hang out by the
theater you're just there night cuz like
700 p.m. like 7:00 to 9 it's okay 7 to
9: so I'm like I've been to the promade
night and it is a ghost town no it's
always always like packed with kids at
that hour on Friday and sorry okay I've
never been there 7 to 900 I've been
there like oh there's a bar down there
and I'm like there's no one [__] here
well yeah bar at bar hours yeah
everything's closed why would anyone be
there but um I don't know cuz it's
[__] where I live you'd hang out by
the movie theater you'd hang out by the
movie theater you wouldn't really see
movies you just kind of hang out and she
was just there with her friends and um
apparently it's illegal to sit down on
the promod so she sat down and a cop
came over and wrote her a ticket there's
people sitting down there all the time
it's not
legal what what yeah everybody just calm
down what's who's crying why why he
keeps getting out and then crying he
just needs to sit in his bed yeah he
wants his bed hold on very needy come
boy very very needy we got a needy and
we got curious good boys Buzz is curious
he's Curious George that's insane yeah
it is Weir um I I told this story on
whatever questions video I've been
arrested before but for [__] like I
wasn't doing anything wrong it was like
because I owed money for a ticket story
yeah I'm not going to tell that story
I'm going to tell the story of how I got
the ticket in the first place I was like
16 or 17 I think and uh um I used to
take the car and just go for like big
long rides cuz that's like what you do
for fun when you live in the middle of
nowhere especially when you're 16 or 17
you just got your license it's like I
anything yeah [__] yeah but um in
Upstate New York there's like a lot of
rural roads and Rural towns and the
speed limit will go you know it's just
like a two lane road there's just one
going that way one com that way and um
the speed limit would change from like
50 to like 20 in like a sign and then
anytime after that sign if you're going
over 20 like you're supposed to know
where you are and just slow down before
the sign happens cuz there's only one
[__] sign and then once it's there
then you're like fair game so these cops
sort of like sit in these speed traps in
rural parts of Upstate New York because
they're just waiting for people to get
[__] so I was in my zuu Rodeo
listening to our Kelly's the world's
greatest it was summertime it was just I
don't even know where I was but it was
you know maybe an hour and a half away
from my house cuz I was like cruising no
friends just me and I'm like I'm up in
the pick up H I'm like just [__] yeah
[__] yeah all of a sudden we would like
I'm like [__] man like what am I getting
pulled over for I'm in the middle of
[__] nowhere and he's like oh you
know that sign was like the speed limit
you're in now entering you know Palmyra
County some [__] and I'm like a dude
like [__] I didn't even hit like the
little little ass town yet like I'm
still outside the [__] town I'm in
just cornfields and I'm like [__] man so
he gave me a ticket it was $300
[__] dollars so the moral of
the story is I learned about myself
after that day I have songs that are on
the do not playlist in my car I have one
on you you know about mine you just like
you hear it and you just get so out of
control that you don't know what you're
going to do when you're driving cuz
you're just so [__] into it on my
driving do not playlist is R Kelly's
world
greatest can't can't listen to it in the
it's not safe it's not safe I almost
crashed um when we were listening to
Treasure by Bruno Mars I almost hit the
car in front of me cuz no you almost
Reed no that is on the do not playlist I
didn't rear them no for the record cuz I
was like J yeah that was a close call
but it was all Bruno Mars's you were
just you were jamming out to Bruno Mars
cuz we're in there like give me all give
me all give
me yeah that's why I got so close cuz we
were both jamming out and then you just
stopped jamming out and realized oh man
just imagine if we were all teenage
girls daddy's Tahoe life is so
distracting treasure among many songs is
so distracting so distracting what's
your song I was thinking about that I I
feel like my song changes um
yeah rather be right now is prettyy
dangerous it's pretty dangerous rather
be is pretty dangerous right now
Fireball by pit it makes me want to
drink Fireball it makes me hyped up it
really makes me want to drink Fireball
right like have you heard that song no I
have we should play it no okay we'll
play it later not right now yeah okay um
but all the it's like pull doing his
thing and then it's p doing his pull
thing my mother by the way referred to
Bruno Mars as the ultimate showman
that's that is a direct quote from my
mother not like Michael Jackson like
Bruno Mars Bruno Mars This was pre Super
Bowl which we watched here yeah oh we
did watch that here she was intently DVR
it at home and has probably watched it
multiple times since then yeah the Bruno
Mars concert with the football game yeah
that one that one that one the one that
had we ordered 100 wings that day 100
and then what did we do after we ate
wings no and then we went to sprinkles
that's right we did we went to sprinkles
we went to sprinkles we got cupcakes at
the sprinkles ATM sprinkles ATM cuz we
put in our card and then they got out a
cupcake that's the
ATM Marvel I cannot believe that your
mom called him the ultimate showman the
ultimate showman and it was like this
really he's good but really I know the
ultimate and so we're my mom lives in
Northern California so we chat on the
phone when we can I got to meet your mom
she's she's a lot like your Mom they're
going yeah uh like my mom then all three
of they're three moms in a pod my mom
I'm pretty sure is still on here right
now hey yo ma hey yo ma let them get
into a bottle of Rosé and oh no just
then we just leave clear out Moses and
bacon but no we so we were talking and
she's like oh you going to watch the
Super Bowl and I'm like probably I think
I'm going to go to Jenna and Julian
we're going to watch the Super Bowl oh
Bruno
Mars he's just the ultimate showman I'm
so excited oh my God she she said it
just like that I admittedly am not the
biggest Bruno Mars fans but I don't want
to like rain on my mom's parade so I'm
like on Super Bowl Sunday oh that's
really yeah yeah he's great Mom it's
going to be it's going to be such a good
show it's going to be the yeah he really
is that's really funny that is so funny
the ultimate show I mean Bruno Mars it's
just a funny thing to call I don't I
just don't think that he's been around
long enough to be the ultimate anything
the ultimate showman ultimate anything
he's just I mean he's just not at that
level no no maybe someday though no not
someday we can just let your mom have
that though ultimate in The Last 5
Years sure so here's another like minor
detail detail about my mom she has a
framed signed poster of
Sting hanging in our
house
legs it makes sense it adds up yeah it
it it does make sense it adds up ni yes
that's good oh used to love
stinging love sting it was so fun she's
she's like always had it too so like
growing up it was always fun to have
people over and have them be like what
the [__] is that poster of Sting doing
hanging like prominently in your house
mom's I can't even hate because my aunt
got me a framed signed picture of Bob
Barker which I love very much sound
pretty good do you still have it yeah
it's I don't think it's in the house or
if it is it's in the guest closet I
don't oh my gosh I don't quite have the
Huts Spa to just have it in the center
of the wall the huta um but yeah I I it
like I I think I like almost teared up
when she gave it to me I was like so
excited because my like dream in life
was just to be on the prices right
and uh it never happened never happened
never happened my mom recently was like
I want to get us tickets to go I'm like
Mom it's not really the same anymore
it's not I was a child it's it you can't
I mean Drew
Cary he's not he's he does a great job
but he's not Bob Barker he's no Bob he's
no Bob big shoes to fil no one to Bob
make sure you neuter and spay your pets
or
else or else that's really funny though
a sign picture of Sting signed picture
of I like that it's signed I mean framed
is good but signed it's like the full
package yeah that's good Desert Rose
even more reason that we need to have
our moms together when when it was
Mother's Day uh this year we brought our
moms over here cuz her mom was in town
fed them mimosas and bacon and then just
let them just [__] dance around in
the pool together like they were having
the best time of their lives I know no
the best part to me was my mom I was
like Mom what uh what Pandora do you
want to listen to she's like I don't
know anything and I'm like okay how
about Holland O's radio and she goes ew
holl and O like I don't like them I
don't like Holland o mom yes you do
Everyone likes Holland oats every that's
the thing like she likes them I don't
know why she said that yeah no so I
turned on Holland notes Pandora it
starts playing a holl and notes song she
said I love this song this is holl and
notes if you want like one story to sum
up like how your mom is that's a perfect
story ew holl notes I love holl not and
then she started jamming out and then we
have video proof of this you uh Debbie
and my mom started singing holls
together in the pool with their mosos I
forgot they sang this song like yeah
well maybe you should like not forget
things before you just blatantly say
that you hate
people [__] hate them except for this
one and this one and this one and this
one and this one I guess they have some
good
songs so ridiculous get it together get
it together like I was a child when when
they came out and I still know good
music when I hear it yeah she was an
adult she was a full grown adult no
excuse no excuse none we had fed them
like I like how we said fed them mimosas
we like fed them mimosas like they were
little pets when you said that too
that's what I I thought like walking up
and
like yeah the little baby birds just F
them exactly we crushed Mother's Day
dude we crushed and we uh and we like
made a whole fruit salad like B listen
I'll tell you how much they crushed
Mother's Day cuz we had this event at
work with Iggy aelia herself that they
were going to come to and they didn't
come to I couldn't I felt bad but for
Mother's Day like that's the ultimate
sacrifice passing on that ass we we
passed on Iggy and Iggy's
butt just to have a Mother's Day you
know how much I love Iggy I love yeah
now Jenna wanted to I like we have these
things at work and I've never asked to
go to any of them except for Iggy
because I was like Jenna we got to go to
Iggy yeah and uh we didn't um gosh maybe
someday future I'll have another chance
but yes I'm sure she had fun at am
she'll be back she'll be back for sure
everyone everyone loved her yeah that
ass d d I'm sure she's seen your video
by the way she has to have seen it she
follows me on Twitter yeah she's seen it
I love I love her I love her Poppy I
love her love love her puppy Jenna is
Iggy aelia wish I am Iggy
aelia I am am a god
Kanye
Kanye you know what I want to [__]
talk about right now I talked about it
for like three seconds in a serious show
[__] have you paid any attention to
Miley Cyrus's Instagram recently no only
because you've showed me it's [__]
out of control like I think the girl
needs like an intervention in terms it's
a little bit past that like she's out of
her [__] mind well I really like
Miley I'm going to pull it up going to
pull it up I really like Miley I think
she's entertaining and she's doing her
thing but like the Instagram game is
like getting out of control because she
she was on a break from her bangers tour
for a couple weeks and so she was just
at her house just making non-stop arts
and crafts which Jen Jenna explain to
people why that's a Telltale sign of I
feel like I've had friends that get into
drugs and they for some reason depending
on make
arts depending on what drug they're
into but for some all they do is arts
and crafts for some of them that get
into certain types of
psychedelics all of a sudden it's just
like they make the shittiest [__]
arts and crafts you've ever seen they're
like isn't it so [__] cool man you
want to come over and just do this for
like 8 hours and you're like no dude I
don't because I'm not four and a
four-year-old can make that better than
you can yeah no that you got to find the
Arts and Crafts I'm telling you yeah
look at the crafts I mean in that
patient she just looks like she's dead
just I think I should know that not that
scroll down Miley looks dead yeah you
got to get to the break she looks dead
yeah see all this [__] dead no like
she's been making like ponytail well
when we uh when we edit this together
we'll throw we'll throw these pictures
in the podcast so you can see what we're
talking about this ponytail holder like
yeah she go we'll show pictures she
likes to loom she's into the loom she's
into the looming listen Miley didn't
have a childhood no she didn't not so
she's doing drugs and having a childhood
now she's doing drugs and having a
childhood now that's the best way to
describe it oh my God it's all Billy
Ray's fault he just thrust her right
into that Spotlight to chase that dream
that he never reached Molly I want to
live through you we're terrible people
we're saying all of this I don't care
Miley where's the next stop on your
bangers tour dad why don't we just split
a bed it'll be cheaper Dad no you're
nasty knock knock dad there you're
nasty Dad I'm on a break from the
bangers tour and all I want to do is
make ponytail holders with my homework
dad don't you got to call from your
teacher you got to test mom no the best
was when you were like your manager
called again he said he quit
again he quit again oh your manager
again he just wanted to remind you again
again that he qu that he doesn't work
for you oh man you know what I think
next time if that ever happens again
Billy Ray uh I won't even will I need a
wig I probably will need like the mullet
wig even though oh you might need to
commit to a real mullet oh just for
Billy
Ray hey you know what if the right if
the right opportunity presented itself I
could just be Billy Ray I could just
help me how is it is there a bottle
opener right there I don't see oh wait
no what am I saying I have one on my
little pocket knife oh yeah help Miley's
Instagram is a mess we're we're checking
in with our Ustream here oh yeah yeah um
who that who that who that this this
comment right here this return the
return of Billy Ray Julian solam style
reminds me of like if you see I feel
like I have endless ideas if I were to
have the means to do them do you know
what I mean like if you just take that
one sentence you know what that makes me
think of what if you shot like a mock
Star Wars just starring Billy Ray like
the whole thing is
like it's y it's Billy Ray and we go
going to fight a galactic war against
some people and then I'm going to record
a song so just go to a store and buy it
in the space yeah that's what I'm saying
one song one song and you can buy it in
a store you're you're you're fighting
with a lightsaber and you're in a TIE
fighter just don't break my heart myy
Breaky Heart Mary where you at yeah that
would be an epic short video that's the
type of thing if you did have the means
to do uh Billy Ray and face hey you know
what what all we need to do is get a
just a giant green screen paper put it
up behind us and then I'm in space and
then I'll just do it I don't know how to
animate there's no animating you just
you put a green screen on and you you
use one of the photo booth you would
just be standing in space you see what
I'm saying I want it to be like a short
video where you're doing stuff yeah hey
never say never trust me I know how to
make it look like you're just standing
there in space Never Say Never Justin
Bieber said that and I'm repeating it
Never Say Never Justin Bieber has uh 53
million followers on Twitter
which incidentally is more people that
are even on Twitter but somehow that is
a thing 50 actually I think
it's Buzz did Buzz just knock over the
whole light knocked over the whole light
hold on let me oh my God Buzz you're so
cute
honey oh buzz buzz buzz at least that
one's still on that light has legs man
this one doesn't break this one works
hard that light got legs oh my God BR
you missed it oh my God yeah the the
Justin Bieber 53 million followers
really gets me it hits me right in the
giggles man you know what I mean oh yeah
no it's big time hilarity um yeah
Brett's teeny little Terrier just
knocked down that massive
light something dumb he's very cute so
funny know the whole light fell over and
he just like ran over towards the
bathroom where you were and he was like
I'm sorry I'm sorry guys I didn't mean
it I didn't mean it I'm just being Buzz
all I can do is be
Buzz yeah no uh Buzz being buzz buzz got
legs Buzz got legs Buzz is on Instagram
everyone if you want to find him it's uh
Buzz loves La uh he's got quite the
library of pictures on there he does yes
he's so handsome hey he's active on
social that's how Sasha says it she's
like social that's the first time I've
ever heard anyone Abate social media the
social media girl at AMR want to meet
with me oh she calls it social I've
never heard of that though yeah you're
really active on social I thought it was
always social media never heard
social speaking of which says that
that's just buzz loves La is on social
he's on social he's on the social
machine on on the social machine he's
very social check him out as social he's
social on the media he's I have to help
him because he doesn't have thumbs and
you need thumbs to use Instagram hey
Kermit can do it oh wait Kermit doesn't
have Instagram never mind but um no we
can't get we can't get control of
someone [__] hijack that [__] someone
has the Kermit and and they upload
pictures claiming to be him and then the
consensus is it's him even though it's
not but his Twitter is run by Kermit I
can verify that marbles run by marbles
even Peach uh I sent over the uh login
information to Georgia so she's been
tweeting a little
bit I'm done with that sorry to Georgia
Peach what do you mean you sent over the
login information to Georgia yeah what
does that mean Peach is in Georgia and
she has a Twitter so I sent her the
login information so she can tweet
oh oh I still don't get
itus the the breeder is I'm totally
[__] kidding the dog's not tweeting
being D Oh I thought you were trying to
like say something serious right now I
was trying to figure it
out we fell into gullibility silly Jenna
serious is for adults I is not an
adult I'll fall for everything by the
way I'm the most gullible person you've
ever met I'm pretty [__] gullible too
it's cuz I feel like it comes from
that's why we're both sitting here like
really really you sent to
the no cuz I like to think that people
are just always telling the truth and
like you're just figuring it out I'm
like wait what do you mean you're
tricking me that was mean I'm sorry I
was being confusing that was such a cool
believable story
though I just snorted oh good
snort I really want peach in my arms I
know two weeks yo I know two weeks holy
[__] right I know two weeks Buzz are are
not Buzz Brett are you happy that you
got a dog I'm so happy that I got a dog
for anyone that's listening or watching
would you recommend getting a dog I
would however I would recommend getting
a dog after you're absolutely certain
that it's something that you can handle
because it is a really big commitment
absolutely and um it's not for like 6
weeks it's for a long time for the life
of that dog I know the I feel like the
heaviest part of it is sometimes you
like look at them and you're like I'm
responsible for your whole life like
everything that you do I I'm like
helping you do you know what I mean like
every experience that you go through as
a dog in this lifetime is my
responsibility to make sure that you're
having a good time and just being a dog
right Kermit right he so he's so goofy
looking he's ready for his sister yeah
he is yeah Kermit's going to have a
younger sister Kermit's going to be the
the older brother that's crazy I always
just think of kerit as this young little
goofy thing but now he's going to be the
mature old one no he's going to be a
middle
child cuz marbles is the oldest he's
going to be a middle child he's going to
be the one that we forget about
oh he is such a middle child acts
exactly like a middle child you're so
naughty naughty naughty and and you just
need so much he needs all the time kerit
a he just wants to kiss Brett he
wouldn't kiss Jenna earlier he would
only kiss me it was really funny yeah
that was [__] that was funny Buzz
does that too such bull like won't kiss
me but then he'll kiss someone else
right in front of me like looking at me
yeah like yeah look doing Brett hey oh
it's [__] bet you wish this was you
don't you
yeah good times [__] [__] we
will uh show you Peach all over the
place once we get her I'm going to Tweet
pictures of her and everything I can't
wait so what's the like can you talk a
little bit about the plan like so you're
going to just go like she's flying in
you just go to the airport and pick her
up yeah she gets flown in she's in a
crate um then I go to the airport sign
some papers pick her up and she's mine
and then that's it and that is it and
then uh I have a a collar for her I'm
going to get some clothes for her I'm
going to get a bed for her um but yeah I
mean there's there's already so many dog
things here and it's going to be it's
just going to be great like she's coming
into an environment where not only is
there already two dogs but there's
already one Italian greyhound which it
may sound kind of goofy but uh you know
the things that we have for Kermit and
the way we kind of accommodate him is is
very specific to an Iggy so having that
set up and the experience already coming
in it's going to be so great and
Kermit's just going to love her
they're going to like they're going to
hit it off I know it mhm um so yeah
she's going to be mine in just over two
weeks Jenna's going to take some video
of it so everyone can see
yeah she's been the background on my
phone forever I'm just like when are you
going to get here dude when are you
going to get legs Peach get legs she's
such a cute little baby um she's going
to be a chubby little teeny puppy like a
little fat with a big big paw all right
guys get over him don't mind me were're
just making out keep in your
pants what a good baby buzz
buzz yeah Italian Greyhounds are
especially funny puppies because they
look like they could just be any type of
dog like any breed cuz they they have
these like short little smooshed in
faces and their legs are short like
Kermit was the same height as marbles
when I got him and then all of a sudden
one day they're just like what did he do
what did he do he got legs
like they they just like they grow these
little baby giraffe legs and they're
wobbly it's really really cute I can't
wait to see that happen oh my God hello
buzz buzz you're a baby I got Buzz's
name um because I like Toy
Story that was a question on the Ustream
you didn't just randomly give us that
fact um when I got him from the shelter
they basically didn't have any
information about him they didn't know
how old he was they didn't even really
know what breed he was and they hadn't
given him an given him a name because he
came in as a stray yeah so I pretty much
knew going into it that if I Got a Boy
dog I wanted to name him Buzz just
because I like um names that are kind of
uncommon and I like that I don't know
just sounded like a good dog it suits
him so well yeah it's perfect he's
definitely a buzz you're an
anamia yes buzz buzz buzz buzz buzz buzz
is his name but we call him Buzz puzz
for short Peach is her name and we're
going to call her princess says Peach
for short just to shorten it up and make
it easier you don't know what you're
going to call her yet you might meet her
and you might be like your name is
Peachy
Wei it just like comes out you know what
I mean you like meet them and all of a
sudden you're just like that's right pey
Wii Mei liy and you're like I don't know
what I'm saying but I'll probably call
I'll probably call her lii
Lei I'll probably call her bubble tea
but who knows I guess we'll find out
when I see her and I'm just like you're
not a peach no you never know no never
know never know never know it just never
know dogs are like in box of chocolates
sometimes you get and raspberry we said
that in the last podcast so unnecessary
raspberry and raspberry sometimes you
get in raspberry covered in and
chocolate and then it's got whipped
cream on top of it and then you go and
you eat it in your hotel room all by
yourself wow that was oddly specific yes
yeah I I won't dig into that we'll get
to that later I guess we can do that on
another episode you feel like you need a
lot of
time what else you guys want to talk
about any day what we got I don't know
um I don't know we we hit the police
thing mhm we hit the bad dates and we
talked about Ted Dougs that's right and
now it's crying back to bad dates
because we didn't we kind of like none
of us really qualified for that but I'm
sure that all of us have had situations
where we have been asked out and have
had to get like you want to decline and
you don't know the best way to go about
it oh [__] so weird you start me yeah
you start I don't know I'm having a
tough time thinking of a specific time I
just feel like whenever it happens it's
that like sinking like gross like throw
upy feeling like I'm really sorry um but
no thank you yeah how about no I don't
know that [__] kid when I was in like
fourth or fifth grade
that that might be throwing it way too
far back but he like blew up my school
picture and kept it in his locker and he
was like in love with me and I'm just
like can you stop creep he was kind of
creepy that's a little really creepy hey
at least he didn't blow up your school
picture and put it in his lock oh
wait what about you I don't know
um I don't I feel like I hit on you
pretty shamelessly yeah I liked it um I
took a whole day off of work to just
come in and hang out with you uh and do
something I wasn't supposed to do is
drink at work which I did got in trouble
for it but it was totally worth it sorry
about that I'm not sorry yeah what about
you
sorry um I want to
know spill it Brett spill it spill it
Brett I mean okay well so I I worked at
like coffee shops for a really long time
when I was younger and in the Bay Area
yeah in Bay in Bay so that that's like a
really great situation as far cuz
usually when you work in a coffee shop
you have kind of regular people that
come in you get to know them a little
bit especially the like friendlier ones
the people who care about you and know
that they're spending like five grand a
year at Starbucks or whatever coffee
yeah so um so yeah there were definitely
situations working at Starbucks or
whatever where I would have regular
customers coming in and then you would
kind of start to like build sort of this
relationship with them if you will a
rapport it's a rapport it's yes and then
maybe you one day they come in and
you're like hey I'm going to give you
your drink for free today yeah yeah yeah
and then everything changes because they
get the wrong idea or they're confused
and really you're just like oh well I
just wanted to get you out of the line
cuz the line was long and we talk and
you you ask me like about my life
instead of just being like [__]
Grande nonfat latte like 5 days a week
so that and then so then you know they
ask you out or whatever and then you
have to figure out how to handle that
but so that it's not uncomfortable so
they can still come back into Starbucks
cuz it's their life basically knowing
that you're going to see them again but
KN you're going to see them again so
that's always a very delicate kind of
like I would usually honestly I would
usually just concoct some really crazy
lie about like why I'm unavailable I
want to know sometimes that's easier
though how crazy though well I mean
crazy my cat has
diarrhea no but like at that point
you're like this person is just a
kindhearted person they got the wrong
idea the last thing I want to do is just
break their heart like so you go to
these L I'm also someone who has a
really hard time saying no to people
like I want to like even if it's not
even if there's no romantic feelings
like sure let's hang out I'll be I'll be
your buddy whatever we talk every day
so it's just it's no bueno I just had to
quit working at I can't be in the
service industry anymore because I just
keep getting asked out I can't do this
fcking I got when I when I think about
it in that context I when I was a
bartender I got asked out a bunch of
times yeah every single night creepy
creep shows but that's also why they
hire you you know because you you look
like a pretty girl so we want you to
work here cuz we know that you're going
to make more money for the bar which I'm
willing to play fine let's do that
because when you're very poor you're
like I don't [__] care but I got
asked out by a [__] Bruins hockey
player like in Boston whenever there's
like a Boston athlete in any bar
everyone's like oh my God so and so is
here and I'm like I don't really watch a
fair amount of the Bruins I like the
Bruins sure but this dude was [__] oh
my God I don't want to say what name but
he's just [__] creepy creepy creepy
creeper ton like the type of
stereotypical scumbag athlete that will
literally get black out drunk and then
he'll just stand there and ask girl
after girl after girl after girl so I'm
pretty sure I was working that night so
I'm [__] sober not drunk watching it
all go down and you know he had asked
another bartender he had asked another
drunk girl he had asked just like
everybody like hey man you want to go
like party with me like you're really
beautiful can I get your phone number
and so I'm I was like maybe seventh on
this list of girls that got asked to go
hang out with this Bruins talk top 10
not bad I know but it's just it's like
so it was so ridiculous like you watch
him get like rejected rejected rejected
but you like you know you'd feel like
for the amount of girls that like would
love to sleep with a professional
athlete cuz there's girls like that
everywhere like this guy was so drunk
and creepy that like he just kept
getting rejected and rejected and he
just like as a last Stitch ever was
like yo girl with the pink hair
how about
you I'm like like it's like when you're
in Middle School the worst time of your
life and you're in PE and it's [__]
dodgeball and people are picking teams
and you're last and the person's like yo
girl in the pink hair how about hey he's
got game though how about you I couldn't
think of that
was uh how about you I'm going to pass
but he would there he was there of
course until Clos and he's like hubo no
no dude no like go home go away go go
that wasn't as bad cuz I didn't like
feel as awkward yeah I could just say no
but there are plenty of times in the bar
where you like you have to be nice cuz
you know you're going to be serving them
all night and they might come in there
more than one time in the time that
you're working there and you're just
like go away please go away all right I
have a question please go on the flip
side what is the
best situation you've ever been in when
where someone has asked you out not best
as in the way that you felt but just
like either most creative or most
outrageous or yeah I was uh I was
bartending and um I have a really good
one I wasn't working this night I was
just hanging out with my mom's dog and I
think it was like a Sunday night so was
probably quiet at the bar um and then
this girl who ID met at the bar the one
of the nights before um we had become
like Twitter followes and followers of
each other so she dm'd me are you
talking about me and she said
[Laughter]
uh oh man there's sneaky Julian sneaky
star you were very forward you you said
where the [__] is puppy I was like oh
okay puppy is his mom's dog mom's dog uh
so I was like well I guess but that's a
very important question it's a good
question it's a very good question and I
said well where the [__] is puppy I
guess she's walking down to South so we
walked down to South and um come here
she gave me her number and I didn't even
ask for it it's pretty cool
mhm yep I shamelessly hit on Julian yeah
that's that I Want To Know Your Story
okay love
so when I graduated from high school I
had a group of friends that went
together to the Bahamas for our like
high school trip or
whatever so I'm I'm 18 I'm 18 years old
I'm in high school or I'm just graduated
from high school years drink the Bahamas
you can drink yeah and we went to uh the
Atlant which is this like really awesome
Resort I've been there it was in nasau
yes yes it was insane so when you're
when you're like 18 and you can't drink
legally you can't do anything fun like
legally basically in the states and then
you go to this awesome tropical location
and you can do everything it's like
amazing this is awesome anyway so the
flight there like we had to fly to
Florida and I think that's like six
hours or whatever and then you have a
layover and then you fly to Bahamas
which is another like I don't know two
hours or something so the flight to
Florida we took a red eye and I actually
received the phone number as an
18-year-old of one of the flight
attendants no you did not what on a barf
bag hey that's great I'm 18 years old
dude you're on top of the world you just
graduated high school you're going to
the Bahamas and then that happen it was
swag swag SW swag swg SW SW SW SW SW I
did feel kind of dude yeah you're a
baller that's so sick on a barf bag
that's super like they didn't they
couldn't even care to be like romantic
they like you know what I'm giving you
my number all there was no official
United Airlines stationary it was the
like even but like a cocktail napkin no
thank you I want to give you this bag
[__] so you
remember oh I actually kept it for a
long time I I wonder what I ended up
doing with it cuz it's just one of those
things that you're like this is the
phone number that I got from this this
is a barf bag and that's a phone number
[__] happened that happened hey
that's a story and a half that's really
dope yeah that's really epic what did
you
do uh he [__] strutted off that plane
like the man he was no I mean like so
well so obviously the flight the flight
ended at that point
um
but there was a later time where we did
actually hang out with each other what
oh my God the I can't believe I'm
talking about this where did you hang
out I I received
word that basically the flight attendant
was going to be in San Francisco like I
was I was living in the Bay
Area I'm like yeah sure I'll come hang
out with you in your hotel I received
word yeah well done well done it was
yeah I have not told many people this
story and now you told the whole
internet I've told that the whole
internet okay well done well hey I'm
pretty sure no one heard that story was
like man [__] that dude no we like
you're the man right now 18 years old
yeah but nothing cool has happened since
then
so to balance it out or something that's
my one and only oh my god dude that's
pretty good that's good that's good like
I like how I don't know they're on a I
mean come on you're a flight attendant
you have to have some sort of in your
mind backup a plan to when you see
someone you want to hit on what you're
going to do nope they were just like ah
scramble scramble scramble barf bag true
you know and I'm sure you can relate
jenno like when you work in the service
industry there are people who come in
that you do want yeah to hit on but you
can't be you you have to handle it
delicately yes for sure unless you're
just like I don't give a [__] like I
didn't really give a [__] see and that
happens too like where you meet that
dude where you're just like I don't give
a [__] like either this is going to go
well or they're never coming back in
here ever again and I can handle that
mhm that's what I felt like
yeah and I'm just going to [__] throw
it all the way out there and if you
don't give it back that's cool see you
later bye you suck [__] you [__] you
suck and [__]
you you suck [__] you suck [__] you suck
[__] suck [__] [__] jump what is [__]
what am I what am I [__] jump what am I
what this jump that's the best video
ever that's an OG internet video have
you ever seen that Brett I haven't okay
what what is jump what what is it's
called what am I what am I what am
I what am
I I probably look crazy because you've
never seen it watch after this yes we'll
watch it we can link the video in the
description we'll do that for you yeah
um
yeah yeah uh awesome time hanging out
with Brett on the podcast yeah we love
you Brett yeah this is really cool love
you guys thanks for having me this is
not going to be the last time you will
not skip out on us no
I'll come I'll come you'll be a regular
yeah this is this is good I'll just be
here you better yeah a yeah or else [__]
you that's a threat that's a
threat if you want to experience the uh
tweets firsthand you can follow him
right here on the on the Twitter machine
I'll show you guys his Twitter um just
say it cuz this will this no I'm going
to put a graphic right here it's it was
going to be show up on the computer yeah
it will I'm going
to all right you know what I know follow
him here follow no here down here oh
sorry up here oh Sor it'll be in this
vicinity Jesus um but thank you guys for
watching and of course special thanks to
Brett and Buzz for showing up and making
this an awesome podcast y we got legs
tonight we got legs tonight we got all
of the legs we got all of the legs all
of the legs like marbles is trying to
but he can't we got all the legs do you
know how many legs I got why can't I
dance on the bar why can't I get legs
you said that have leg why did you take
away my legs I want my legs back I would
like my legs back please you don't even
by the way I wait I have a quick the
first time I met Jenna was at a bar and
do you do you remember there was a girl
there go trying to climb up on the bar
oh my God you tweeted at us about toally
[__] forgot about that the first time
I met Jenna we were at some bar at the
garage there was nobody
there it it's not in a particular
location for that type of
Satur La Hollywood Bar where there's
like tons of people and it's like was
super lowkey we're sitting there
drinking cider and beer it's really just
chill they serve food right it's like
it's like basically a restaurant it's a
sports part yeah no I mean how there
were probably more people eating there
at the time than they were drinking and
then out of nowhere you mean like
there's two people eating and three
people
drinking us three and then there might
have been a couple at a table this girl
[__] who denies herself like into our
conversation it wasn't even like she
appeared next to us it was like all of a
sudden she's like literally standing in
the middle of the three of us and she's
trying to climb on the bar on the bar
and there's always got to be a girl
who's trying to climb on the bar why
can't I get on the bar she didn't even
do any of this she just went for it for
it she went for it like she was climbing
the jungle gym man she had no [__]
she went this is what happened in my
psychic brain she went to the bathroom
with her friend and she said why do you
think I can't dance on the bar this week
like I asked him and they said no so I
think that I'm just going to go out
there and dance on the bar
anyways anyways and she just got legs
and got up there oh God she got legs
well she half got legs and then they're
like no you can't do that ma'am no no no
get off you see that there's a family
over there you're stepping on that guy's
fries get off the bar oh I remember that
cuz uh first of all I remember it cuz it
happened and then I remember you tweeted
about afterwards [__] phrased it
really funny I just remember looking at
her and she she looked like she was a
zombie just like
[Music]
crawling girls climbing on bars when
they're drunk is like it's like a zombie
it's it just
happens it's like what their it's like
uh you know their their mammal instinct
is when I'm drunk I need to get on top
of that bar to
survive I need to mate and therefore I
must climb onto the bar I need to spread
my pheromones from up
higher that's disgusting and I can't
believe I just said that way to end it
beautiful ending to this lovely podcast
that we've had just I'm GNA spread your
phermones from up higher spread them
spread them on top of the bar get legs
and spread them then more people can
smell them in their drinks and their
food it's all over the place
pheromones excuse me I need to put my
pheromones on the bar let me get up
there you don't understand my clock is
ticking so I trying to get up as high as
I can as fast as I can increase my
chances of getting a baby oh gosh
preferably by an affluent white man and
if you don't have a baby for me I'll
take another vodka oh my
God make it a double vodka a double just
charge me for a single just kidding I
actually have a baby in me he's said
home without a baby
but if you have champagne no no I have a
baby and meat but the dad like I don't I
don't want this one so if you have a
champagne or 10 oh is that is that the
line we crossed the line we walked right
up to the line and flipped it off that's
all the time we have for today I don't
want this one can I have another one can
I have yours what are you
doing DJ crippy JW
oh my gosh well that was a beautiful
ending that was great someone someone on
the Ustream said where the heck did this
conversation go that's what I that's
what I hope for all these podcasts to
just get on the weirdest [__] tangent
by the way Welcome to our lives like
this if we weren't podcasting this right
now we would still be talking about yeah
the only difference is you guys are
getting a little insight into our crazy
weird conversations you're getting an
insight you're getting an Insight yeah
book it means you look
inside
[__] oh my God like if you if you got
a pair of 3D glasses and you put them on
and then you looked
inside you'd see this you'd see this
podcast good night good night good night
good night oh buzz buzz buzz say goodbye
say goodbye Buzz we'll see you again
soon thank you guys for watching we'll
be back with another podcast soon
hopefully with another guest and you
will definitely be seeing more of Brett
more Brett
and we love you love you love you all
right good legs bye bye good
legs